Hi everyone. So first of all uh great to
see you here. I'm my name is Daniel
Glli. I'm a postto in the autonomous
systems lab in the department of
aeronautics and astronautics. Uh as you
might guess from the accent I'm also
Italian. So if optimal control doesn't
work for you I guess you'll be experts
in Italian accents at the very least. Uh
so for uh for today the the plan is that
so you know over the last week we
started introducing the general
formalism for optimal control
specifically we introduced uh the
general problem formulation which is
something along the lines of we're given
um dynamical system
x of t
which is in the form of a differential
equation and the overall So goal for us
was to determine an optimal uh control
uh signal U star of T that minimizes
some
objective
which we defined as having like a
terminal cost H of X of TF. So the final
time tf
plus our our running cost
>> and then so this we realize that this
was in kind of an infinite dimensional
yes
>> can you use a different
>> all right um so let me again nothing new
here this was just what I was saying
here is we defined the optimal control
problem as a dynamical system
uh where we wanted to define an optimal
control u star
of t. And this control then kind of
steers the state trajectory x of t uh in
a way that we can optimize an objective
function
j which is composed of two terms a
terminal state uh terminal cost h of x
of tf so the at the evaluated at the
final time plus a running cost again uh
I don't want to kind of just uh don't
take too much out of this exactly
because we saw this already uh and then
given that we realize that this is an
infinite dimensional uh optimization
problem. We then went into kind of
opened up parenthesis about final
dimensional optimization where we
started by defining first of all what we
mean by minima or maxima. kind of uh
that are the objects of interest for us
and then we went into uh defining
necessary optimality conditions for the
uh unconstrained case first. Namely
the fact that gradient of f
of x needs to be equal uh to zero. So be
a stationary point of our uh objective
function f.
uh and then we did the same for uh the
constraint case namely the equality
constraint case. And so for today we'll
just quickly wrap up uh last week's
lecture where we will be defining the
necessary and optimality conditions for
the inequality constraint case and then
we'll move to the content of today's
topic uh which are then essentially our
first step into the op into optimal
control where we'll be trying to have a
similar approach that is defining
necessary optimality conditions this
time for the infinite dimensional
optimal control problem. Any questions
on the plan and does this make sense?
All right.
Okay. So, first of all, when we say uh
inequality constraints, we essentially
refer to an optimization problem of of
this form. So, we're minimizing as usual
objective function f ofx subject to some
equality constraints, which is exactly
the setting we were seeing last week.
So, h of i of x needs to be equal to
zero for m equality constraints. And
then here we're introducing r inequality
constraints represented as gj of x needs
to be less or equal than uh than zero.
And we're assuming here that fh and all
the gjs are continuously differentiable.
Again kind of this problem can be
written in compact form uh which we will
be referring to as the ICP. So the
inequality constraint problem uh where
we are essentially compacting this in in
vector notation. So all the letters
become basically boldface.
But this is the kind of problem we're
looking at when we say inequality
constrained optimal control problem.
And the so when we introduce inequality
constraints kind of mathematically this
object becomes much more uh difficult
and we could spend uh a series of
lectures into defining the optimality
constraints for this case. Um however
what I will do today is uh essentially I
will try to take uh kind of an easy
route in defining the optimality
constraints and what I mean by easy
route is that we will try to reuse as
much as possible what we derived last
week with the equality constraints and
the way we do this is through uh
something which we refer to as active
constraints. So specifically for any
feasible point the set of active
inequality constraints is denoted as
this a of x which is essentially the set
of all the inequality constraints gjs
that are respected at the equality.
On the other hand, all the uh other
constraints that are not respected at
[clears throat] the equality, so are
strictly less than zero, we will be
defining them as inactive at x. So more
visually
say that we have a problem along the
lines of minimizing
x + y subject to
the fact that x and y must be greater
than zero and x + y needs to be less
than three.
What we're looking at is something where
first of all it has to be in the
positive side of the plane and then we
have
this constraint here which essentially
defines the feasible region to be this
one over here. Can you guys see from
from the back over there?
Yeah. So in this case it's kind of the
minimum. So if you look at the level
curves of our objective functions there
are something that look like this
and so in this case the the minimum
point would be at the origin. So if we
take this point so
0 0 at this point out of the three
constraints we have that these two are
respected at the equality. So these two
would be active.
On the other hand this constraint over
here is not respected at the equality.
So this is inactive.
Okay.
And so given that this definition is is
clear kind of this point is where uh
most of the I would say the brain power
for understanding this uh this easy
route goes into um specifically what
we're saying here is that if x of is a
local minimum of the ICP which is the
full problem that we saw on the previous
slides. So this one here
what we're saying is that then XAR is
also a local minima a local minimum for
the identical ICP without the inactive
constraints
and to give you an intuition kind of the
proof for this argument usually goes um
by contradiction so we're saying that X
of is a local minimum of the original
ICP so with all constraints included uh
but let us assume assume that this is
not a local minimum for the problem
without the inactive constraints. So if
it is not a local minimum, what this
what this would mean is that we would be
able to move in the neighborhood of that
xar
uh while respecting the constraints and
still finding a better value of the of
the objective function
at the same time. And so if we are
moving into a neighborhood, we can find
a neighborhood that is arbitrarily small
such that the inactive constraints
always remain inactive.
Right? And if you're following me until
here, what we're saying is that if this
is true, then all the constraints of the
original problem would still be uh
satisfied. And so this would mean that
we would have found a better point also
for the original problem. Therefore kind
of concluding the contradiction here
right so
if you will
again don't take me by kind of the exact
uh word here but what we are saying is
that we can always think of a
neighborhood of this point xar so if
this is not a minimum of this problem we
can define a neighborhood that is
arbitrarily small such that we can move
along this minimum and find a a new
point x prime
such that the value of the function at x
prime is smaller than the original f of
xr
and specifically since I can take this
neighborhood to be as arbitrarily small.
I could move in the direction that it
satisfies all of my original
constraints. So the equality constraints
but also the ones that are inactive
because the inactive ones always have
you could kind of think about it
intuitively as there is some margin that
I can play with right and so if this is
true then I would have found a a point
that is better for the original problem
as well and so this is not the case
does this make sense
okay
and so what we're seeing here is that uh
at a local minimum active inequality
constraints can essentially be treated
uh to a large extent as equalities.
And so you're probably starting to guess
a little bit where we're going now. Uh
so remember what we're trying to do here
is define the optimality conditions for
inequality constraint problems. And we
said we want to take the quote unquote
easy route of leveraging as much as
possible the results that we got in the
equality constraint case. And so here
what we just proved is that if x is a
local minimum of the full problem that
is uh the full inequality constraint
problem then it is also a local minimum
for the version of the problem where I'm
only considering the active constraints.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. For when you're saying that it's a
local of the constraint are you assuming
that you're not on the boundary because
even with that example if you cross the
boundary out of the constraints you
could be going lower but it would not be
the local zone.
>> Yeah. Exactly. So this is what I meant
by don't take it like too rigorously
here because here there is actually only
this one point that we're considering.
Uh but maybe you could imagine something
like in three in three dimensions maybe
where I have my inequality constraints
being some uh kind of hyperplanes
and kind of satisfying both means lying
on this subspace over here. Then you
could kind of think that moving in a
little in a neighborhood of this point I
could still respect my original
equality constraints. Does this does
this more sense?
>> As long as you are not on the boundary
essentially is what that previous point
was saying then that is true.
>> You are on the boundary you can cross
the boundary and become a a lower.
>> No of course we want to respect all the
constraints.
>> Okay. So that previous point only you're
saying only is of concern if you are not
talking about
>> by previous point you mean that the
>> if the local minimum of that then it's
also a local minimum without the trait.
That's only true if the local minimum is
fully within the boundary and not on the
local minimum is a feasible point. Yes.
[snorts]
>> No. If the local min is within the
bounds and not on the boundary
>> like if it's on x
>> well in this case it is a boundary.
>> Yeah. So, but if crossing the boundary
outside of the constraints means you
have a lower point, then the the local
minimum without the active traits is a
different local minimum than with the
constraints because you're once in the
boundary, one's not in the boundary.
>> Yes. If you're well, if you're going
across the boundary in the invisible
region, then
>> then yes, then yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So then that is only true
then when you're within
you're not on the boundary right 0.1
>> I mean again is the fact is that
boundary here it depends because we
boundary I guess you're saying when
these constraints are active so some of
them will be at the boundaries and some
won't.
>> Yeah. So I guess I'm confused where you
think it's a local minimum without the
constraints just because you have a
local minimum within the constraints.
But if you're in the boundary that's
kind of signature cuz what he talked
about the previous thing is like on the
boundary you might have a more like
minimum you might have a lower value but
because you can't cross the boundary you
have to keep building on the boundary.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So it's only a local minimum
outside of the constraints if you are
within the boundary itself.
>> Yes. I think I think we keep Yes. But
Does the general picture make sense
apart from from this? Yeah.
>> Any other questions
on this?
>> Okay.
Okay. So, basically what we're saying
here is that X is a local minimum of the
original ICP. Then it is also a local
minimum for the same problem where we
remove the inactive uh inequality
constraints and only keep the active
ones.
And if we think back what we did last
week, this is an object we can basically
work with and derive uh optimality
conditions for. Right? So remember that
last time we were defining the
lrangen
as L of X lambda. We're introducing some
uh lranian multipliers lambda equals f
ofx plus the summation of from i to m
which is where m is the number of
equality constraints of lambda i times
uh I think we call them h so h i of x
and then we use this to derive um uh
necessary optimality conditions such
that the gradient of the lranjen
needs to be equal to zero. Right.
>> I think this was the darker marker.
So
again this is from last lecture. So what
we were just saying is that we use this
to define uh necessary don't optimize
the conditions. So we defined the
lrangen and then we just said that the
uh
gradient with respect to this loan
function needs to be equal to zero.
Right? So these were the optimality
conditions in the equality constraint
case which boil down to a system of n +
n equations in n plus m uh unknown. And
so what I'm saying here is that this is
exactly the same case now that we did
this uh step.
And so we can apply the exact same
reasoning in defining the optimality
conditions for the ICP with the inactive
constraints removed
where again uh this is exactly the same
necessary optimality conditions we
derived for the equality constraint case
with the addition of this term over here
which takes care of the only the active
constraints
that is the inequality constraints that
are respected at the boundary. here
uh where again we have this lrangen term
muj star time the gradient of the
inequality constraints and everything
has to be equal to zero or equivalently
we can write the exact same thing. So
here nothing new just rewriting uh a
little bit more elegantly where rather
than having a summation over only the
active constraints I can have a
summation over all inequality
constraints so from R1 to R uh with the
additional condition that the mus need
to be equal to zero for all the inactive
constraints.
there is an additional condition that is
the uh multipliers mu.j that relate with
the inequality constraints have to be
positive. Uh there are some kind of
geometric interpretations and proofs we
could do here but it's beyond the the
scope of this of this lecture. Yes.
>> Do you have a concept of
equality constraints also
sort of
>> uh well I mean the equality either you
are at the equality or you're not
respecting it right. So it's slightly
different I think.
>> Doesn't does it make sense? Yeah.
>> If we solve this for the global minimum
with respect to like the active
constraints, are we guaranteed to also
be satisfying the inactive ones or is it
something we have to iterate on?
>> No, this is this is exactly the the
point I was trying to make earlier that
we again we kind of did a sketch of a
proof. But what we proved here is that
if X is a local minimum of the original
problem, then it is also local minimum
of the problem removed the inactive
constraints.
>> Yes. So here the entire goal is just to
come up with optimality conditions.
>> Yeah.
>> So there's a lot of terms here. Can you
knock a G H2
your example?
>> What what does any example? With the
example, you mean this one here?
>> Yeah.
So in this case, there are no hes. So
this is f our objective function. There
are no hes because h for us is the
equality constraints. So here we are
assuming we only have inequality
constraints. And all of these would be
G's. So like this would be G1, this
would be G2 and this would be G3. Of
course, here I'm not respecting the um
formalism that I'm whereby we only use
less or equal than zero. But you could
just flip the sign here and get that.
>> Does this make sense?
>> And then what about?
>> So A is the set of active constraints. A
of X is a set of active constraint at a
point X. So it depends on the point. We
were assuming we have this point here as
our X. In this case, a of
0 0 which is this x over here would be
uh these two constraints. So one and two
>> because this is inactive.
>> Yeah.
>> What's the
>> uh so here for us we're just defining uh
a of x as the set of active constraints.
So we are not talking about regions
necessarily. We're just referring to a
you it's literally a a set of indices.
So in this case it will be one and two
referring to constraint number one and
constraint number two.
>> Can I repeat this?
>> So to find that set
you just plug in the values point
>> for example.
>> Yes.
>> Um so then I guess I like a little more
clarification. So how would you then
identify like for example 0 0 one and
it's one and two that are active three
isn't is it like then is active if
you're like right on the boundary so
that's why the third constraint's not
active like if you say moved it to three
[snorts] 0 would it then be that two and
three would be active.
>> Yeah exactly. Yeah. So active is when
you substitute the value of x and y here
and you get an equality out.
>> Okay.
>> Yes.
>> Is this thing for equality constraints?
Because if like it's constrained to be
on two lines and you're not on there, do
that just means that neither of those
are satisfied as well or is it just for
inequality constraints? I I don't think
I got something
>> like is there a similar thing cuz unless
I'm missing the point of the active
constraint thing it's just like kind of
the area that's satisfied by all of
them. So would there like everything but
>> you're talking about the physical set?
>> Yeah. Yeah. For equality constructs is
there version of that?
>> Uh I mean if
say that we have
indeed this problem here. So you imagine
we have two equality constraints such
that in of course in three dimensions
right? So we want one equality
constraint is you have to lie on this
plane. Another equality constraint you
have to lie on this plane. Then the
feasible region is this this part over
here.
>> Yeah.
Okay.
All right. So all of this to kind of
boils down towards the necessary
optimality conditions for the inequality
constraint problems which are known as
kucker conditions or KKT uh which
essentially goes as follows. So we once
again define the lrangen function L of X
lambda mu where lambda mu are lranian
multipliers. Um we then used you know we
use this object then to define the
optimality conditions. And so the
theorem of uh uh basically the K
condition states that uh if x of star is
a local minimum for the full uh
inequality constraint problem uh where f
h and j's and g's are all continuously
differentiable
and we assume that xar is again kind of
uh you can ignore this for now but in
general we're saying that the equality
and active inequality constraints are
gradients are linearly independent.
then it means that there exists a unique
lranch multiplier vectors. So the
lambdas and the mus such that the
gradient of the lranion is equal to
zero. Uh the mujs in correspondence to
the inactive uh constraints are equal to
zero and in general they're all positive
so non negative again. So here we're
just putting together the results we we
uh we arrived at.
Okay. So now to kind of ground the
intuition a little bit.
>> Yes.
>> So in this case we only checking the
boundaries right because we're only
checking when it is equal to and so if
we find one on the boundaries then we're
like cool we found that we never check
on the boundaries right?
>> Uh this so the this is a necessary
condition meaning if a point is a local
minimum it has to satisfy this condition
over here. So it does not mean that all
it so what it means is that all local
minimums satisfy these conditions.
>> Yeah. But for example x of 1 one which
is none of those constraints you have
there in terms of the equality
[clears throat] constraints.
>> Um because it's not x= 0 it's not y= 0
and it's not y + x= 3. Um it would never
show up in your set. Um like a of one
one would be nothing in the set. So you
would never have it on there. Um but it
could be a minimum in this problem.
>> Uh x of 11 one could be a minimum
>> like yeah it could be because it
satisfies all the constraints. Um and
let's say the gradient and it fulfills
where the gradient is right. Um but it's
never being checked in your problem
because a of 11 one is nothing because
it's not equal to zero. X is not equal
to 0. Y is not equal 0. And x + y is not
equal to 3. Um
>> I'm afraid I'm not exactly following
your argument, but I would have to kind
of take that on on you because we have
like a full lecture to to cover. I'm
happy to stay afterwards if you want
offline. Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Is it a necessary condition that at
least one of the inequality constraints
is active?
>> Uh a necessary condition and that what
>> to solve the point like to have it be a
solution for the problem. uh that at
least one of the constraints is
inactive.
>> Uh so you know it's a property of
problems that usually solutions are at
uh tension points between objective
function and constraints and so usually
yes. Yeah.
>> All right. So
to make a small example of of what it
means to apply this hopefully to ground
the
intuition.
So let us solve this problem over here
um where we want to minimize x^2 +
epsilon squ subject to one inequality
constraints that is 2x + y less or equal
than two. Can you see with this marker?
Is it good enough?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
All right. And let's be uh methodical,
right? So let's uh apply the KKT
conditions. So first of all, what we
need is we need to compute the
gradient of f
which in this case is simply 2x and 2 y,
right? and the gradient of our uh
inequality constraints so grad g which
is 2 n1
right so we're using this to to
characterize the
uh gradient of our lang
and the inequality constraints are
slightly trickier in the sense that you
need to consider cases right in the case
of the constraints are active or
inactive and so let's look at the first
case one where we are assuming that the
constraint is active. That is that 2x +
y is equals 2.
[snorts]
Now we indeed write the that the
gradient of the lrangion is equal to
zero condition which essentially means
that 2x
y plus mu
times our gradient of our constraints is
equal to zero. Right? So this is our
gradient grand has to be equal to to
zero.
And of course we also have that the
muses need to be positive. Mu needs to
be positive. Well, non- negative
from this we can write that 2x + 2 mu =
2y + mu = 0 which essentially means that
x is = mu
and y is = mu / 2.
Okay.
All right.
Uh now if we
plug these into our active constraint,
so we have values for x and y,
what we get is 2 mu
equals to two, right?
which essentially means that
mu is equal to 4 5
which is not possible because we want
muses to be positive well no negative.
So this is uh this is not uh kind of
what we need here.
[laughter]
All right. And so we try with a second
case
two which is where we assume that the uh
constraint is now inactive meaning 2x +
y it's strictly less than uh than two.
Now in this case we know that for all
inactive constraints the mus are equal
to zero and so our gradient of the
lrangen essentially becomes
2x 2 y plus zero because this is mu *
the the gradient of x of g
which essentially means that
x and y are equal to zero.
Now this satisfies the constraint
because if we plug these values here it
is indeed less than two. And so this is
indeed a candidate for uh for a local
optimum. And to convince you that I mean
this this was not like a hard problem
because just to convince you that what
we did makes sense.
What we are characterizing here is a
problem where uh we wanted to
basically satisfy this inequality
constraint
which defines this line over here. And
so the feasible region is in this part
of the of the line. And our objective
function is like a a ball that
originates in 0 0, right?
And so indeed the the the local minimum
here and well global minimum in this
case is 0 0.
>> Yes.
>> Apologize if I missed it before you
explain why we use zero case. Uh so here
we defined that uh if you remember how
we derived the KKT conditions is that we
essentially defined the problem to be uh
identical to the equality and so we
derived this condition over here which
could be equivalently rewritten such
that we were iterate so summing over all
inequality conditions inequality
constraints with the additional
condition that the muse has to be zero
for all the inactive constraints and so
in In this case we were in a case where
we were assuming this constraint is
inactive and so for this constraint the
mu has to be zero.
>> So when the conraint is inactive here
the mu is equal to
>> yes correct.
>> Again here what we're saying is that you
know this is an example of how we could
use these these uh optimality
conditions. So we did all of this work
to say to come up with an condition that
we can use for to potentially filter for
candidates. So we use this, we find
potential candidates for optimality and
then we check if it makes sense or not.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. This is the point I was I'm happy
to share with you some some literature.
It gets a little bit tricky. Uh there
are some geometrical interpretations but
they're beyond the scope of this class.
Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Multiple
combinations.
>> Exactly. This is where it gets tricky in
here. We you know we kind of used only
one constraint. Yeah.
Uh well uh no right because here what
we're saying is that the so this these
are the conditions so we're just
applying the conditions nominally
uh and basically the conditions entail
that for all constraints the muse has to
be non- negative except for the ones
that are inactive where they actually
have to be zero.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. So am I incorrectly that the
conclusion that we drew from checking
case one is that there just would not
exist a candidate for optimality that
has this active constraint.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. [clears throat] Correct. Again,
here is one simple example of how you
could use optimality conditions just as
a way to filter out candidates. Yeah.
Okay. And so this uh actually wraps the
um content for
uh lecture two. So let me just grab
Okay. Any any other questions on this
before we move on?
Perfect.
And so kind of with this now we uh
essentially you know laid the foundation
of some intuitions that relate with
finite dimensional optimization. And now
we are kind of and this is important
because we will be coming back to these
ideas kind of over and over in this
class at the very least for the optimal
part uh of this of this class before we
go into into learning. uh and now we
start essentially exploring our uh road
map and this is a slide we will be
coming to over and over because it just
uh helps you I think in in in grounding
uh what we're covering exactly and so
specifically for the next two to three
weeks uh we will be focused on this uh
quadrant of our road map that is
openloop methods for optimal control
which are to be uh differentiated from
uh closed loop methods which entail
finding a closed loop policy for for
behavior. And specifically for the next
three lectures within the class of
openloop methods, we'll be looking at
indirect methods which is historically
how optimal control started uh back in
the 60s and 70s. Um
which and so we will look at indirect
methods and then move towards uh direct
methods which on the other hand are the
more modern and way modern way to to
solve optimal control problems in
practice. [snorts]
So what are indirect uh methods? So uh
at a high level uh indirect methods are
essentially a mechanism for which we
basically go and define and determine
necessary optimality conditions for
optimal control problems and solve for
those. So if you wish kind of everything
that we have been doing so far in the
finite dimensional case. So we have
defined these optimal control problems
depending on if they're uh constrained
or not. We derived optimality conditions
and used as we just did for example
these optimality conditions to filter
out candidates for optimals for
minimums. uh in the exact same way
indirect methods try to use the exact
same formalism that is define optimality
conditions and use those to filter out
solutions this time for the original
problem which is uh the one we were
looking at at the beginning uh which is
you know the one in infinite dimensions
right so we're looking at the dynamical
system
um
which is with the you know objective
function that we were describing before
and what I mean by the fact that this is
actually an infinite dimensional
optimization problem is because while
here uh kind of variables are
essentially vectors in this case we are
interested in optimizing
kind of a full signal u in between uh
time t0 and F. So you should imagine
that for us e u of t is the full signal
that we want to optimize not a single
point.
Okay. And uh indirect methods are also
known as optimize then discretise. And
this is because optimize refers to
deriving optimality conditions which
kind of as a as a spoiler in the case of
uh infinite dimensional problems. These
optimality conditions as we will see
today will essentially end up being
differential equations. Um and then
discretized because these differential
equations in order to solve them we
typically feed them through solvers
numerical solvers which entail some
discretization
uh and these are to be kind of
uh compared to direct methods which on
the other hand are usually referred to
as discretized then optimize. So we are
given a optimal control problem in
continuous time. Uh we discretize time
by for example using a specific
discretization of time replacing
integrals with sums with summations and
so forth and then optimizing this finite
this you know this discrete time
problem. And so you can see how these
two methods are in a way nicely
complimentary.
And but so why do we bother uh kind of
going through these ancient tools such
as indirect methods? And the point is
that sometimes um indirect methods
provide a more direct that is analytical
or semi-analytical solution for the
optimal control problem which is great
because it means that uh at deployment
on board we have to do very little
computation which is great in the case
where we have only limited uh compute
environments. For example, in aerospace,
these are highly highly used. Uh and at
the same times, indirect methods are
also typically used to maybe provide
initial guesses for direct methods. And
so the message here is that I'm not
wasting your time.
Um
as a so these techniques are usually can
be quite mathematically challenging. Um
and this is because it's kind of as a
result of this uh books and textbooks
and material is generally written by
mathematicians which is great they're
perfect but also sometimes they do not
really uh follow the you know this is
the rata of control engineers and so I I
definitely advise you to go through this
reference over here which I think
strikes a nice middle ground.
Okay, so in general, so we, you know, we
were referring to this problem before,
but so now we're taking the first step
into tackling the optimal control
problem kind of at first hand.
And again, what we're saying is that we
want to find an admissible control U
stars, which causes the dynamical system
defined by a differential equation to
follow an admissible trajectory X of
stars that minimizes the functional uh
J.
And what we saw last week and at the
beginning today is that for a function
uh we essentially defined optimality
conditions that boil down to setting the
gradient to zero to find stationary
points and then either using higher
order derivatives to determine whether
these are maximums or or or minimums or
uh just iterate through all of the
candidates and check if these are
feasible and if uh what is the minimum
among these candidates.
um we'll do something very similar for
function function out uh which is the
extension of a function in infinite
dimensions. So loosely speaking
functionals are
can be thought of as
functions
over functions.
[snorts]
And again very mechanically what we mean
by by this is that uh u of t in this
case is an entire signal an entire
function as we were saying before and j
which in this case is a functional is
something that takes as input a full
function and uh and spits out uh in this
case a scalar number which is a measure
of optimality
and the tool uh I'll be using today to
introduce these and derive these
optimality conditions is uh referred to
as calculus of variations which is a
generalization of calculus that allows
to find maxima and minima of functionals
specifically by using variations and
we'll see uh more in in the next slides
what we mean by uh variations.
Um, calculus operations is even more
ancient than indirect methods. Dates
back 3 400 years. Uh, and it's really
kind of a fundamental uh kind of sub
field of of calculus.
And once again, uh, these topics can be
extremely heavy from a mathematical
standpoint. And so in order to be kind
of focused on what is the goal for us in
this class, what I'll try to do here is
that I'll essentially be constantly
mapping between the results that we want
to obtain in the infinite dimensional
case that is through calculus of
variation to the intuitions that we
built in the finite dimensional case uh
in order that is probably the setting we
are all most familiar with. Um and
specifically uh we will start by so if
you look at this agenda this is
essentially the onetoone mapping on what
we did on uh last week Monday. So we'll
start by introducing concepts for uh
functionals. Um for example defining
what is a functional uh what it means
for a for two functions to be close to
each other. What it means to be a
minimum or an extreme point for
functions. Uh and then we will use this
to uh derive what is referred to as the
fundamental theorem of calculus of
variations. Uh that is the necessary and
optimality conditions for the infinite
dimensional problem. And then we'll
apply this to optimal control.
Any questions on the planet
or questions so far in general?
Okay.
All right. So, what I'll be doing for
the next 15 minutes is probably a bit
boring, but it introduces the
terminology notation that we need going
forward. And so specifically a
functional j is a rule of correspondence
that assigns to each function x in a
certain class omega say the class of
continuous functions um a unique real
number
and it is always useful to look through
an example. So for example a possible
functional is this functional j of x uh
which is the integral between t0 and tf.
T0 is just a number say three. TF again
just a number say six. Uh of X of T and
DT where X of T could be any continuous
function for example.
And a specific class of functionals we
are interested in is the class of linear
functions um which are defined by the
fact that they respect uh two
properties. The first one is
homogeneity. So the functional of the
scaled version of a function. So here
alpha * x is equal to the scaled version
of the function. So alpha * g of x
homogenity.
>> Okay. Thanks.
And [snorts] the second one is
additivity.
[snorts]
That is the functional of the sum of two
functions
is equal to the sum of the
functionals applied to the individual
functions
which um together uh lead to the
superposition property.
So as an example, the previous
functional is uh linear because say that
we are
um
you want to do J of alpha x which
essentially means the integral between
t0 and tf of
alpha x of t
in the t. We can carry out the alpha
from the integral
which is equivalent to saying alpha j of
x.
Again nothing deep here but just uh
proving that uh the example here is
indeed respecting the homogeneity for
example and you can do an equally simple
proof for uh for the dativity.
Okay. So next, so remember that to
define um what is a minimum for in the
finite dimensional case, we use the idea
of uh being optimal in a neighborhood.
And to define neighborhood, we
essentially need needed to have the
concept of closeness, right? And to
define closeness in this case of
functionals, uh we resort to a concept
that is exactly the one we use also in
finite dimensions, which is the one of
norms. And so specifically the norm uh
in the case of uh of of a function is a
is a rule of correspondence that assigns
to each function x again in a specific
domain omega uh a real number and it is
defined as we do in uh finite dimensions
and it satisfies the following
properties that is the uh norm of a
function has to be non- negative and the
it has to be equals
and the norm is of a function is equal
to zero if and only if the function is
equal to zero for all times.
The second property is that uh the
scaled version the norm of the scaled
function is equal to the uh absolute
value of the scaling factor multiplied
by the norm of that function for all
real numbers alpha and it has to respect
the triangular inequality.
And in practice to compare closeness
between two functions say y and zed what
we do is we let x be the difference
between the two functions and we measure
the norm of that difference.
So it might seem as we are doing
nothing. Uh but what we're essentially
doing is just carrying over all of these
results. We have infinite dimensional uh
infinite dimensions to the infinite
dimensional case.
Uh as an example uh consider uh kind of
the continuous functions X. Uh a
possible uh definition of the norm could
be the maximum between T that goes from
T0 to TF uh of the you know absolute
value of X of T. And you can see that
this uh is indeed does indeed satisfy
these uh these properties. For example,
the value of the norm is by definition
always non- negative because we're
taking the max of an absolute value. And
the only way the norm is zero if it is
um zero across all times because we're
indeed taking the maximum. So this is
for the first property but indeed I do
invite you to check the other two
properties but just as an example of of
what is a norm for us.
>> Yeah. So the set omega do the functions
in that set have to be related to each
other at all or or is it something that
we choose individually?
>> No, I mean omega here is pretty general
definition. It could be the set of
continuous functions. Yeah.
>> So in this case they are related but I
would say just uh a domain for our
functions. Yeah.
>> Could you helps
Yeah, this is a good point. Uh, so
essentially um the way we do in finite
dimensions is we use norm kind of
loosely speaking to uh measure kind of
distances between vectors, right? So
usually what works in infinite
dimensions is literally to revert resort
to your intuition in finite dimensions
and trying to map it to the infinite
dimensional case. And so here we're
doing exactly the the same thing. We're
using norms over functions, not over
vectors, to measure kind of distance
between functions. And we can use this
distance to measure quote unquote
closeness. And we this will become more
practical in the next slides, but this
is more or less what we're doing.
>> Does it make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Just to clarify that the norm is being
taken of the difference of the two
functions, not of each.
>> Yes. Correct.
Okay, so we're getting toward towards
what we actually care about that is this
uh defining extrema for functions. Um so
now that we have a measure of closeness,
we can actually do the exact same thing
we're doing in finite dimensions. And
specifically um
a functional j uh has a local minimum at
xar of t. Again xar of t is a full
signal just so that we don't get
confused in the as we would do in the
finite dimensional case. Um if there
exists an epsilon greater than zero uh
such that for all functions that are uh
kind of close to the local minimum that
is the distance between these two
functions is smaller than this epsilon.
the value of the function is uh greater
or equal than x of star. So again exact
same results that we have in finite
dimensions uh exact same means of
getting to the result but we're just
extending it to the infinite dimensional
case.
>> Yes
called um x oft a signal wouldn't the
signal be you
>> uh yes this is a good point. So here we
are kind of introducing these ideas from
kind of a high level uh standpoint. Uh
for us we are interested in optimizing
control signals which is u. So in
general here we're using x as a general
notation but in practice we will always
be optimizing you. Yeah.
[snorts]
Okay. And maxima of course defined
similarly just by uh kind of uh flipping
the sign.
Now to define
uh minimum we need to define something
uh that is similar to the differential
of uh of a function. And just for
as a reminder,
remember that to derive the necessary
optimality conditions in the finite
dimensional case, uh what we did is that
we essentially were looking at the
increment
of a function. And we saw how uh this
could be approximated by
kind of the value of a function itself
uh plus the gradient of f transpose
delta x plus some high order
terms
where this is what we called
differential.
Right? So this is exactly what we did on
on Monday
and specifically the re the the reason
why we did this is that we use the fact
that for small enough uh increments
delta x the value of a function is well
approximated by this linear part and
then what we did is that we used we
essentially derived conditions on this
linear part to say something about uh
the minimum of the of the function
specifically ally we went from the uh
from this differential to the condition
that the at the minima the gradient of f
needs to be equal to zero. So this is
what we did on on Monday. And so
intuitively what we want to do is
something very similar actually exactly
the same but again in the infinite
dimensional case.
And to do this we start by introducing
an increment of a functional that is
defined as the difference between the
value of functional evaluated at the
function plus a variation of x uh uh
minus the value of the function at uh of
the functional at the function itself.
And now is where I think again kind of
most of the brain power goes. Um because
so here so we introduced so at the high
level this is what we want to do. So we
want to do follow exact the same recipe
that is um define something similar to a
differential and use this linear part
that well approximates our function to
derive a condition on this linear part.
uh in the infinite dimensional case. Um
to do this we need to define um a notion
of differentiability.
>> Yes,
>> that comma is supposed to be plus right
>> sorry
>> the x of t comma delta x of t is that
supposed to be plus right
or is it not?
>> No no this is this is correct. So we're
defining the increment which we express
as uh as a basically as a function of
the original function x of t and the
variation
>> but that equals the what you were
talking about x plus delta x right
>> no this increment would be
f of
>> a completely different function than the
j that you were talking
>> uh no it's this part over here. So if
you bring this on the other side, this
is the increment because it's the
difference of the value of the function
and this is the difference of the value
of the functionals
>> of the function else.
>> Yeah, functionals.
>> Yes. Does it make sense?
Okay. So here what we're essentially
doing is expanding the concept of
differentiability. Um and to do this we
first rewrite the uh increment in this
way and specifically the increment we
rewrite it as the sum of delta j which
is a linear part plus some stuff and
this some stuff is uh kind of the
equivalent of the higher order terms in
the finite dimensional case. And so here
you might say well sure we can always
write something as something linear plus
some stuff. The point is that to define
uh what it means for a functional to be
differentiable, this stuff has a
specific property. And specifically what
we're saying is that if uh the this part
g goes uh to the limit of smaller and
smaller delta x's goes to zero we have
something that goes to zero times
something that also goes to zero which
means that this higher order terms goes
quadratically to zero. Well, this is a
linear term linear in in delta x which
means that goes only linearly to zero
which means that the increment of the
functional uh for smaller delta x is uh
well approximated by only this linear
part. So again we're trying to do the
exact same um statement that we were
doing in the finite dimensional case.
And so again, so this is the notion of
differentiability. Meaning that given
that we are rewriting the increment in
this way. If this condition is true,
then the function of J is set to be
differentiable on X and delta J. So this
term over here is referred to as the
variation of J at X.
Any questions here?
Yeah. Is this definition coming from
or is this completely different?
>> Can you can you repeat another
definition for the init coming from the
Taylor series you've talked about before
or is this completely
>> it's a it's a great question because in
a way like I this everything that I'm
saying here is not actionable meaning I
haven't told you how to get any of this
and so we'll see later in the next few
slides how to do this. Uh so here what
we're only doing is setting the stage
for for that result. Specifically by
setting the stage I mean that we are
trying to draw parallels between what we
were doing in the finite dimensional
case and here expanding the notion of
differentiability.
>> Was that a question or no?
>> Yeah. So for now we'll just say
>> for now it's just uh it's just a result
that is taking a step into how we
actually compute.
>> Yes.
>> Sorry.
But what the geoc?
>> Yeah. Again, so here I have not defined
concretely what any of this is. Um,
intuitively you can think of this part
over here as the equivalent equivalent
of the higher order terms in our tailor
expansion. Yeah.
Okay. And so this uh kind of once we
have this we can formally state the
fundamental theorem of calculus of
variations or again kind of i.e the
necessary and optimality conditions for
our infinite dimensional uh problem.
Specifically the theorem goes as
follows. So let x of t be a vector
function in of t in the class omega and
j of x be a differentiable uh functional
of x. Again differentiable meaning that
the increment is well approximated uh by
the linear term delta j that we are
seeing before. Assume that the functions
in omega are not constrained by any
boundaries. For now ignore this
sentence. If X of is an extreal, the
variation of J must vanish at X of that
is the necessary optimality conditions
for our problems is that the variation
of J at a local minima uh XAR needs to
be equal equal to zero for all
admissible uh delta delta X small
enough.
Uh so again here we won't uh be uh kind
of bringing forward the proof because
it's fairly intricate and in my opinion
not super insightful. Uh but in a way
how I want you to interpret this result
is that this is exactly the analog of
the
gradient to f transpose delta x equal to
zero condition that we saw on Monday.
Now in the finite dimensional case this
was um directly leading towards an
actionable thing we could compute which
is the gradient of f equal to zero
condition. Uh in this case this is not
yet actionable. Uh but we'll build uh
towards it but intuitively and at a high
level you should map this result exactly
to the differential equal to zero result
in the finite dimensional case.
Yes,
>> this is like a lower case delta J. In
the previous I use a capital delta J.
>> That's the same thing.
>> We're talking about this linear part
over here,
>> right? So the capital delta is the
increment.
>> So the difference between the value of
the function,
>> right?
>> Uh well plus the variation minus the
original function. And the kind of lower
delta here is this um is what we're we
introduce to be as a variation again
kind of in your mental model I would
suggest you see this as the equivalent
of the differential. So it's the linear
part that approximates very well the
increment
if
in the finite dimensional case what we
did is that once we had this linear part
that approximates well the different the
increment we derived a condition on this
linear part
here we're doing the exact same thing
does that make sense
>> what what is big No. Um
I'm not sure I understand what the
difference between the increment and the
linear part is
why there's a difference.
So the increment we're just defining it
as as the difference between the value
of a functional at the kind of function
plus variation uh minus the value of a
function at the original the functional
at the original function. So this is
just a definition. Um then what we're
saying is that we can for variations of
the function delta x that are small
enough this increment is well
approximated by a linear part. Uh and
then we use this linear part to
basically impose a condition on this
linear part to def to derive our
optimality conditions.
Again, I understand how this can s can
look a bit vague because here it's still
not really actionable yet. In two
slides, it will be
okay. But again, so fundamental theorem
of the calculus of variations is the
analog of the differential equal to zero
condition in the finite dimensional
case. So the necessary and optimality
conditions in the infinite dimensional
case. Yes. is delta x in the delta j
function there is that the variation of
x over time.
>> Yes, correct.
>> Um actually this is a good point. Let me
try and give some intuition to what
delta x is.
So
say that this is our x of t. So our
function x of t. Um
we can define uh and this is like t0.
This is tf.
Uh delta x could be a function
that could be something like this. So
delta x is in itself a function which
leads to x plus delta x being something
like this. So this would be delta x and
this would be x of t plus delta x
>> and then would still be all of that
plugged into the [snorts] I guess the
integral that you were talking about as
the example.
>> Uh we didn't define what delta j is here
yet. you should just uh see it as the
linear part the analog of the linear
part uh that will approximate the
increment in the infinite dimensional
case.
Yeah.
>> Okay.
Okay. So we now let's make this uh
actionable and to do this let's start by
um applying it to basically an extremely
simplified optimal control problem if
you wish kind of the simplest possible
uh optimal control problem we could
think of. Specifically, we consider the
problem where um we want to minimize
this uh functional which is defined as
the integral between t0 and tf of this
function g um which is a function of x
uh the derivative of x and n time. So
going point to the uh observation that
your colleague was doing before here you
should interpret this as we want to we
are as if we are directly controlling
the state trajectory for example. So
there is no control but we are directly
steering the state trajectory of our
system.
Um and so some assumptions here is that
G is uh twice differentiable. We're
assuming that t0 and tf are fixed. Uh
again this is something we will relax uh
on Wednesday. Uh but for now we assume
that the initial time and the final time
are fixed and given. Same thing for the
state at the initials time and the uh
final time x0 and xf are also fixed. So
kind of to to basically uh recap what
we're doing so far we have introduced
the fundamental uh theorem of calculus
of variations which is the optimality
conditions in the infinite dimensional
case. Now we which we said is not really
actionable and operational yet. uh so so
now we will make it operational by
starting to look at a simplified version
of an optimal control problem which we
will be building on uh on Wednesday to
the until we reach to the full-fledged
uh optimal control problem.
Okay. So [snorts]
um to do this let's apply the uh
fundamental theorem of uh calculus of
variation
and specifically what we do here is we
write the
um increment uh so here we're not really
doing anything particular we're just
applying the definition of an increment
and then we're substituting our value of
j uh from our optimal control problem.
So for us the increment will be defined
as the integral between t0 and tf of g
of x + delta x x dot plus delta x dot t
in the t uh minus the uh original
functional at g. Uh we can bring the
second integral inside the first uh and
we get this equation over here. So
completely nothing new here. We're just
applying the uh definition of an
increment with respect to the our
definition of J in this problem which
was this one here.
Okay. So just a note on notation uh x
dot is the derivative of x of t and dt
and delta x dot is also the derivative
of delta xt.
Okay. So
remember that
what we said in the for the fundamental
theorem of calculus of variation is that
we took the expression of the increment
and then we said that the increment
would be equal to a linear part uh delta
j plus some stuff. Now here what we want
to do is from this equation here we want
to extract the linear part of this
functional over here.
Now
in general
assume a fixed t so we are considering
only if you want one element of this
integration. What is the tool we would
usually use to derive uh kind of linear
the linear part in this case?
Taylor.
>> Yes, exactly. Correct. So, we will be
using tailor over and over in this
class. And so, this is exactly what we
do here. So we uh basically do the
tailor expansion of u the the term
inside the integral whereby essentially
the increment becomes the integral
between t0 and tf of gxx t uh plus the
derivative of g with respect to uh x
which we refer to of g of x times uh the
variation in x plus the derivative of g
with respect to x dot times the
variation in x dot. plus uh some higher
order terms. So here we just expanded
the the first term if you wish.
Uh
now from
uh if you look at this the first term
and the last term cancel out and so what
we are left with is uh only with these
three terms over here
and even by inspection
uh
what would you say it like out of these
three terms where are we sure the linear
part is not coming from? So I guess
you're you're probably guessing this
higher order terms element, right? So
even just by expection. So we tailor
expanded our increment and we are
defining our variation that is the
linear part that that well approximates
our increment as this uh [snorts] this
guy over here.
Does that make sense?
>> Yes. Does the
term in there that's just the Z O
parenthesis does that just represent all
higher order terms
not considering?
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Okay. Now uh if we look at back at the
uh fundamental theorem of calculus
operation which is what we want to apply
we were seeing that the condition that
we had is basically that the variation
of x delta x needs to be equal to zero.
Now what we got here is the uh variation
but this is also a function of uh x dot.
So what we're going to do here is we're
going to massage this term in order to
have everything as a function of uh
delta x.
>> Yes.
Delta j to small delta.
>> Yeah. So uh if
let's see if it's somewhere here. Um so
if you remember the way we did it kind
of abstractly is that we defined capital
uh delta j so the increment as some
linear part plus some stuff right uh
what we're doing here is we want to
derive the linear part for this specific
case. So we started by uh just applying
the definition of increment to our
specific functional which led us to this
um
well actually it led us to
uh this this guy over here. Then we
wanted to extract the linear part and so
we use tailor expansion of this first
term to uh get a linear part which led
us to this here the first and the last
term cancel out and out of these three
terms here we have this higher order
terms which is definitely not the linear
part we're looking for and so we're just
left with the middle two.
>> Yeah.
Okay. Okay. And now we said we want to
express this only as a function of delta
x not delta x dot. And so we want to
massage this second term. The way we do
this is through integration by parts.
So remember that
I think we just printed.
Okay.
So remember that we
uh integration by parts essentially
entails uh doing this. So the integral
of u uh dv is equal to u * v minus the
integral of v du.
And now we want to basically apply this
in the context of our second term. So
what we have is
this one here from integral from t0 to
tf of g of x dot x x dot t
delta x dot in the t. So we want to
apply integration by parts on on this uh
on this one here where
we're considering this as u and this as
uh dv
and
this essentially means
uh well applying the the integration by
parts. So we have g of x dot x x dot t
delta x dot
delta x
0 tf.
So this is the first part
minus and I'm not sure if you're able to
see but unfortunately I'm out of dark
markers now. [laughter]
Um, so the integral between t0
and tf
let's try again.
Ah, now this is great. So the integral
between t0 and tf
of uh
delta x times the uh derivative
in with respect to time of g x dot x x
dot t
in the
which essentially means that
um now if we take this and we kind of
write the full uh variation delta J what
we're getting is the integral with
respect between t0 and tf of
g of x
x dot t
minus the derivative with respect to
time of g x dot x
tx
t plus
the g x dot
t also computed between t0 and tf
[snorts]
right so here I'm we inte use inte
integration by part to u massage the
second term here and then we just
rewrote the full uh variation delta j.
Now if we
look a little bit closer at uh the last
term over here.
Actually, I think I forgot
uh delta x here.
Yes.
So if we look at this term over here, uh
we can safely say that all of this is
equal to zero.
Because at T0 and TF the variations that
are admissible in our X are actually
none, right? So we said that X at T0 and
X at TF are fixed. And so the variations
that are admissible are are are
basically none. Uh again visually what
we're saying is that
um in our problem we have fixed x of tf
and x0
at t0 and tf. And so this means that we
have some fixed boundary conditions for
x. And so the admissible delta x's here
are none because all of my points need
to pass there. And so if if these are
all zeros, then this entire term is
equal to zero. And so we're left with uh
this term over here.
Okay. So,
so for us we're basically left that the
fundamental theorem for calculus of
variation results in uh this integral
over here in z tf
of g of x x
minus the derivative with respect to
time of g of x dot x dot
dx dt equal to zero. Right? So our
condition for fundamental calculus
operation is that this guy is equal to
zero. And so here we are just setting
delta j equal to zero.
>> Yes.
But is the admissible DX that you're
talking about captured
in that DX? It's in the bucket or is it?
>> It's in the DX this one here.
>> That's an admissible.
uh I mean in general we are uh looking
at the variations of our functions uh dx
and for the problem that we're looking
at the admissible variations of x at the
boundary points are are always zero
>> oh
okay that is
>> yeah and so I just want to wrap this up
so I don't steal too much of your time.
Uh but essentially what we're saying is
that for us the uh fundamental theorem
of calculus of variation leads to uh
exactly that condition over there
which is the one I'm written here on the
slide.
Uh now does this tell us anything about
the uh inner like the integrant term
over here?
It does and it does so through the last
result that I'm introducing today which
is the fundamental lema of calculus of
variation which essentially says that um
for any continuous function h so any
given continuous function h the integral
between t0 and tf of h of t time delta x
uh so if this is true so if we have this
result here this is only true if
um h is zero everywhere are in the
interval t0.
Uh what is the intuition here is that
say that this is our
h of t
and these are the possible variations
delta x of t. Uh given if we have any
variable function h of t say one that is
non is positive at some time t. If we
were to pick our variations adversarily,
our delta x of t, we could always pick
the point that kind of matches the uh
variation in x in order to make this
positive. And so the only way in which
this entire integral is equal to zero is
if h of t is zero everywhere.
Does that make sense?
So through this we essentially are
finished in the sense that we arrived at
our
condition here. And then we said that
the through the lema we know that this
essentially means that
this would be our h and this is delta x.
All of this integral is equal to zero
only if this part here is equal to zero.
And so here we have fasttracked Newton
uh basically took you know 20 years we
took 45 minutes to reach to the same
result uh and we arrived to the
necessary optimality condition for the
infinite dimensional case which is known
as the uler equation. Uh I'm out of time
so I won't stick further but I'll recap
this on on Wednesday. Thank you.